I slept at the gym cuz I didn't have
enough money to pay two rent I went to
California without knowing anybody and I
found this guy online who had a good gym
so I just asked him if I could just work
for free and so he ended up paying me
minimum wage but he got on his gym floor
on a stool and was like anybody want to
give this guy a place to live cuz I had
just driven there without any plan and
one guy came up to me he's kind of like
you can stay at my place I got a bedroom
for you and so we actually are still
friends to the day and he was like hey
just get me to stop eating and drinking
so much on the weekends and we'll call
it a fair deal